hey guys I'm Jade and today we're gonna
find out if we dance better when we're
sober oh really
tips I've danced pretty much in the
whole life doesn't mean I'm good but
dance doesn't have to be good it just
has to be pure from the heart I think
I'm gonna be better drunk
that's the honest chore that didn't that
you just like let loose feel the vibes
so we needed some unbiased opinions to
judge this fairly so we brought in some
professional dancers I'm vexed Robinson
and I'm a dancing since I was two so 20
years I love dance because it's a form
of expression and freedom for me it's a
way to communicate without saying words
what's going on everybody my name is
Eugene Cho I also go by b-boy loosely I
am 25 years old and I've been dancing
for 13 years around when they're gonna
dance the three songs completely sober
and they're gonna drink a little bit
take a couple shots then they're gonna
do the same three songs again the truck
[Music]
yo
[Music]
nobody's watching my dreams I'll be back
I gave him a 7.5 because I thought that
he was still on the music even though he
was like super tired towards the end
gave her a 8.5 because she's on beat the
whole time and also she's so telling
which a lot of people don't do you use
your space great you just gotta get out
of your head so I'm excited to see what
the tequila does
[Music]
[Music]
jeez
[Music]
like Eva a because his music a lead it
was actually a little bit better and
also he had more confidence so I give me
[Applause]
your I feel like your confidence and
last one was like like up there and as
you were in your head this one lady look
at her score all the confidence that you
had first of all different human known
right right now than it was before and
those hips are you kidding me
like I think that's a shemitah rain
[Applause]
[Music]